claudia you're just coming to life
i can see it in you and you're taking
control
of your life and i applaud you for that
thank you claudia this is gonna be the
end
of the american idol journey for right
now thank you so much
it's the end of the road for claudia
conway on american idol
i hope you learned a lot and i hope you
come and see us
again and another contestant faints
on stage
[Music]
[Applause]
when it comes to claudia conway the 16
year old singer was sent home on monday
night
following the duets round
[Music]
[Applause]
claudia is the daughter of kellyanne
conway who previously served as a senior
counselor for former president donald
trump
the singer was paired with 17 year old
mississippi native hannah everhart
and the two had a rocky start that is
not what i was expecting who
did this everybody was laughing but it
wasn't funny
and she's apparently tick-tock famous
but i didn't know that
because i don't stay on tick-tock yeah
claudia has gained a
pretty big following on tick tock where
she often feuds with her mom
over their political views and they're
paying attention to you because they
know
that you need extra help what'd you call
them what do you want to know
as for hannah and claudia the two didn't
exactly see eye to eye at first
when i first met claudia i was like oh
crap and then like i was like okay
i'm gonna go eat um i just need to like
recollect my brain
right now hannah even disappeared for a
sec to collect herself
you know watching all the other pairs
working together and collaborating it's
kind of
it's kind of frustrating me you know i'm
here to win i'm here to
do the best that i can i'm here to
collaborate with my partner
but there's no partner to collaborate
with the two
eventually started rehearsals
[Music]
and after they sang their duet of sign
of the times by harry styles
judges katy perry lionel richie and luke
bryan
sent claudia packing and hannah on to
the next round
i appreciate that you both made a
conscious
choice to work together but you didn't
carve out enough
individual time and despite the
disappointing news
claudia seemed in good spirits cheering
on her duets partner
and new friend i'm so proud of her
because
you know she deserves it more than
anything
it has been wonderful working with you
um i really appreciate
your support i'm gonna be cheering for
you you could win this thing
but claudia wasn't the only contestant
to make headlines
[Music]
following rhonda felton and funke
lagoke's beautiful performance of tell
him
originally recorded by barbara streisand
and celine dion
moon cave fainted hitting the ground
face first
[Music]
[Applause]
the contestant was treated for
dehydration and released from the
hospital a little later
you were on american idol would you get
through it yeah i don't know
i mean because because i didn't get my
confidence i mean i'm
still getting my confidence to be
completely honest and when e.t recently
sat down with the judges they weighed in
on just how hard the competition really
is
it's mental gymnastics and it's really
like
it's the master class obstacle course in
a
crunch period amount of time i think
lionel said something the other day you
know
you can't let other talent
psych you out that's right you have to
be what you are
and what you are just because this
person may be
technically the best singer in all of
america i don't they may not have the
personality
that you have they don't have the x
factor so
control what you can control handle your
[Music]
business
you